citizens of the reject Nation Greg here today
we are going to do a first time watching for
the movie you're next directed by Adam Winger
the director of Godzilla versus Kong I know
this is a home invasion Thriller that's about
all I know I've never seen a single clip or a
frame of movement from this film before I've
heard it's good it's been recommended my way a
bunch of times it's Halloween season horror is
actually my favorite genre covered Sinister a
couple months ago you guys should go ahead and
check that out as well and also on my list I
have the movies X and Jennifer's Body put in the
comments which one you want to see next and yes
Gotta Give a disclaimer here YouTube's been extra
extra sensitive as of late and uh this has got
a hard R so if some things have to be you know
blurred or whatever censored please understand
that when a video gets age restricted that also
means that YouTube kind of hides it buries it so
even though we wouldn't be monetized we would
not even get views for it so I just don't want
that to happen when I know this is going to
take several hours to put together but guys
please go ahead leave a like also subscribe
click the notification Bell to get notified
when we got a reaction up here that piques your
interest as always and I am very grateful to all
who have joined our patreon page and become super
sexy rejects over there we have our full-length
Reaction watch alongs as well as covering several
shows where you got reaction highlights and watch
alongs exclusively for several of those IPS and
uh the team at prepper thank you for helping
us set it down these highlights I'm excited
guys let's get into the horror slasher mood
oh we are off to the races people
she doesn't now it looks satisfied
I don't know her but my Primal instincts
are telling me I am now emotionally invested
oh oh come on be smarter than that and I
would immediately call the cops all right
and now would be a good time to call the cop
that's the title of the movie oh
nice like a good blood Splat
on the wall if you guys are
fans of Supernatural you get a lot of that
I love that horror movie shot of
the Woods and road on the woods
road on the woods that's a sentence that's funny
uh that's not funny at all dude so your
parents are pretty loaded right I guess
my dad retired from kpg last year and
he got an insane sevens package wait
kpg is in the defense contractor
he was just in marketing though
I'm surprised this is your first time having
this conversation I want to meet your family
my mom's on
a way to ruin the fun with
your mental health problems
oh oh my God
sound is that it's gonna be that easily
thank you oh what a smart woman Aubry oh yeah no
you go outside I'm gonna check the upstairs you
deserve to die I'll take this with me okay are you
happy no all right you wait outside I'll be out in
a minute why would your inclination not just you
should have already just want to take a weapon
foreign
this is why I own RPGs sorry guys this
ain't enough True Crime stuff to be like
home invasion stuff is something
that you should take very serious
oh my God what the hell you
scared the [__] out of me yeah
you're a piece of [__] son you know that foreign
I love the voyeuristic approach
of a lot of these camera shots
hey you come here oh we brought whiskey well come
on in that's a great offer well I look forward
to meeting the rest of your family tomorrow it's
been a long time since we've all been together so
it should be interesting oh it's
going to be a family Bloodbath
oh [__] oh what a great shot it's in the window
and in the toaster oven oh that is awesome hey
everybody you ever see kangaroos fight stop
in a weird way do some funny little Kelly
you almost hit my face
it's only a little chubby this
is only a little chubby I have
a round face yeah it doesn't mean
that's right it doesn't mean he's
fat no it means you're beautiful all the
fat on him means he's fat what a dick
so I guess she's the main character and
we're like experiencing this through her
poker cow for me can you could you go over to the
neighbor's house and see if he has some yeah okay
well I'll be right back it's nice
to feel like you have a purpose
is there a doorbell because
that music is obnoxiously loud
that is messed up man but smart
you must be Terry yes nice
to meet you nice to meet you
meet you I'd like you didn't mean to
see a girlfriend see nice to meet you Z
wait I know that actress don't I you're Aaron
yeah nice to meet you Scott dad maybe horror films
are always lit this way it's like kind of like a
yellow dark tint to it just want you all to know
how much it means to us that you're all here
so thank you for coming oh she's so cute
that poor mom's gonna get brutally slaughtered
I'm a filmmaker is that right yeah I don't think
I know any filmmaker makes sonic it's not
a lot of us interesting I've only made one
documentary was it the Cleveland underground Film
Festival 2008 did they show the movies underground
I just think do you do commercials because
those are my favorites no no he doesn't do
it really I just think that is just
the height of the art form these days
foreign
at this time of night through the
window a beautiful shot can be formed
foreign
holy crap he got an arrow in his head
yeah get away from all the windows right about now
no oh if anyone deserved it
this is pretty intense man Jesus
okay you're rich sons of [__] gotta own at
least one gun right yeah they must be using a
Jammer what a cell phone blocker they're illegal
but you can get them on the Internet for like
30 bucks what are you calling me a low life for
man I'm just trying to help the situation hahaha
I love that I keep fighting
you're right during this
oh my God oh my God it's not gonna work
it's gonna be a two shot it's
gonna be a two for one right now
foreign
crossbows take a while to reload
Ed somebody should make a run for the cars
no man what's wrong with you whoever's
the fastest runner who who is that I'm
the fastest man I've got this [__] Arrow what
does your shoulder have to do with your legs
you guys
pull the doors open at the last second they're not
going to be expected to be coming out full speed
oh you should say her goodbyes
foreign
wow that was unexpected
oh that's horrifying
oh Jesus that's some scary [__]
we need to make sure all the
doors and the windows are locked
what do you mean what she's got the right
[__] idea man what are you doing so
please cover up unlock all the windows
never seen you act like this before
I don't see your next situation yeah
dude go away with me I've never seen
you act like this before she's doing
Jesus Christ she's a goddamn Warrior
damn so there's a daughter like that
right in front of your eyes and the
documentary filmmaker underground film
cinema is never going to be the same
yeah what's this girl's past oh
no oh whoa
this goddamn Pig masks
that's cathartic because
who is this actress she's freaking awesome
oh jeez Geez Louise
what if that guy's still under the
bed no one should be left alone
why would you look without having a weapon
Kelly
foreign
you're so stupid I get you're
not thinking rationally but
wow
ouch solid punch damn
how violence is this gonna be oh gosh
oh no foreign
we need to get somebody out there in here
I'm gonna go to the neighbors as soon as I'm a
safe distance away I'll try to text and call if
there's some big plot twists coming everything's
gonna be fine out there you just stay in here
Crispin you're dead you're dead this is
what happens when you be able to have
unprofessionally in the workplace the safety
say at least one of them's already inside
the person killed my wife stood in this house go
find him what's the best room for a solo banging
I don't know all the rooms have Windows
in them except for the basement no I
suppose that's a bad idea they can just pull
guests down the stairs and throw in a match
who is she
she did know the Kirsten's dad's uh
background how should I carry a weapon
damn homie just burst right in
nice nice bash is heading yeah
she is so cool who is she
that's like a good force not forced head trauma
someone has to ask who she is anyone know this guy
oh she is the [__] thanks
for the help by the way
where's he dead
I already want to know more
about this actress she is so cool
oh man they've been camping out where's the
circuit box I don't know I think it's in the
basement like why don't you go look for it there
I'm gonna go upstairs and try to find my dad
oh poor guy Alex
one of them was in the bedroom
they've been watching us for days this wasn't a
random attack okay okay yeah don't turn your back
oh are they in on it
I've had I mean they're making it they were they
were shooting it was like they were red on it
especially the girl
you had to do that right in front of me
are you saying something yeah you know what
never mind I had a feeling the girl was in
on it I was slightly suspicious of him but
looks like it'd be really hard
to fight through that mask
oh oh
here's Johnny
hey whoa
yes oh yes get him in the face
oh come on guys
you guys okay what's going on we
heard noises so we stayed upstairs
we didn't find anyone and your dad ask
about the dad he just needed to lie down
how many of them do you think there
are to be at least two more of them
you just want to make sure that the
nail goes all the way through see that
who is she she looks so familiar
how did you learn all this stuff
well I had kind of a weird childhood
I grew up on a survivalist compound
I haven't even told Chris Ben that yet
you guys keep a lot from each other
move to the states with Mom when I was 15 but
I've learned a lot beforehand that's crazy
now could he kill his own brother
three Kelly's dead
man her body's up there on the floor right now
oh my God
you just die already this is hard enough for me
that is some cruel [__] man
oh you better not
I'm gonna go check on the dad upstairs
and when the boys come up make sure to
have some rope or something uh
I can do it I can go be careful
laughs
stay on high alert
God damn
survivalist compound lady indeed
awesome
oh my god oh you can feel it I don't
know why you guys ever have once I
almost got glass really caught
in my foot and nailed to just oh
boy
foreign
Rich parents kids look for
something to be mad about
Home Alone
I'll be over soon
oh that's gross oh my God I really in the
mood right now Z come on I'll make it quick
just so we're perfectly clear I might kill
my own brother I'm just trying to think
of reasons why I should kill you he's
paying you we did make it this far man
yikes
I just got a fist ready that's awesome
oh nice oh that is great great
I love her I love her so much
you could have taken the stairs
come on Judo chop him foreign nice
she is so cool I want to take
Krav Maga classes right now
oh yeah bring on the synth music people
awesome I really hope Crispin doesn't
come running through that door
you know how to use that thing yeah
I know how to [__] use it I pull
the trigger air shoots right two bolts
Two Shots you see here you make it count
I am so fascinated by this performance it's such a
cool character such a such a really cool character
I would expected nice flip on the genre
nice Motif I Like It Cool Style
I'm Batman
foreign
she is the definition of fight or flight
get in there
nice
murder her
oh this is so cathartic
oh my God
that's what I'm talking about man holy that is
awesome I love it
oh I love it
wow what an image oh man she took out everyone
that blender death was one of
the most brilliant things ever
no it's crisping in on this
ah what
you know I'm a pacifist I can't I
can't deal with the violent stuff
oh you cowered it's it's [__] freezing
out here I'm coming inside Aaron you're okay
where's Felix
I stuck a blender in his head and killed him
he would have killed me no that was never supposed
to happen you were supposed to be the witness
a person with a clean record that could attest
that our family and neighbors had been murdered by
unknown lunatics things got so out of control you
deserve to die so much I'm now the sole inheritor
of my family's estate we're talking Millions
babe regardless of our current situation or
whatever we're going through that's why
he was like why are you behaving this way
you could have 500 000 within a month or
I go to jail then you get nothing
oh you better kill him
that's right move easily The Right Move
oh God what
stay alive stay alive just a tiny bit longer
we need medic and back up
immediately at five Edelweiss Drive
foreign
oh no the ax
that was awesome
said suspect on her Polaroid
there's cops failing to put it all together
edited by Adam Winger too that's cool all
right guys I'm gonna have to talk very efficient
because uh time of shooting this I have to move
on to editing something else right it's like 11
30 at night or something else I gotta edits this
is weird just uh kind of a funky schedule
this whole week that I've been having but
um I really really enjoyed that there was a a real
cheeky kind of humor to it I loved I loved its
black humor man I love the dark humor throughout
and it was just a really exciting film because
when it starts off it has this like self-awareness
that you think you're sort of walking into uh
traditional home invasion movie where you know
family is going to mingle together and then bam
there's going to be some serial killers to show
up something a little bit more straightforward
and direct kind of like the strangers movies
you know the strangers I I'm I haven't I don't
recall pray at night too well I don't know
I'm sure if you've seen that movie but uh
like the strangers it's a typical home invasion
movie serial killer slasher and such but there was
a lot of great whodunit flares to it and there
was uh it was almost like an Agatha Christie
Vibe about it where you have the family mingling
together and instead of just the body count of the
family members it starts to become a question
of like who's involved who's really behind all
this why is this all going down is it you know
because at first it's sort of leading you into
this belief that these are psychopaths attacking
them and that perhaps there's some type of ritual
behind it you know especially with the fact that
they're riding on the walls like you're next that
it does seem like there's some type of ritual
occurring you're out in the woods and they're
masked up and is there like symbolism behind the
mask but then you start to you know eventually
latch on them so one of these people might be
in on it so I like that there was a bit of this
it's like a physical comedy quality to
it and a bit of a screwball comedy Vibe
uh with a bit of an Agatha Christie Flair
as well with a home invasion Vibe and also
an action movie and a horror movie all in
one I thought that was great like the way
they they fleshed all those elements together I
thought had a great natural build to it because
in the beginning it does feel like some of the
dialogue does feel like a little bit cheesy but
then it just works so well and you know it's there
are parts that feel like a bit of a because I
think a lot of it just comes down to if you strike
the right tone you can get away with certain kinds
of expositional dialogue like when Aaron is
hiding who is this woman by the way hold up
Charney Vinson God I know I'm in a rush right
now but I I gotta know who this person is my
God she was phenomenal I I loved her she was so
incredible I don't think I've seen her at this
I think this is the only thing I've ever seen
her in she is so good I love the the handling
of her character we gotta talk about that because
yeah like they're planting the seeds in there of
dysfunctional family and you kind of think
maybe it's gonna go one specific way because
in the beginning of the film I was sort of going
all right whose perspective are we latching on
to it eventually you know I was like okay I think
this is Aaron's perspective that we are ultimately
capturing this movie from because you're like
is it crispin's perspective that we're seeing
this film through you know he's the son having
to return to his families obviously ambivalent
towards them or watching as he's driving to them
and bringing his girlfriend and perhaps he's the
one who's gonna have to go on a character Arc
and there's like a completely different movie
that this could have been where through the course
of these events you watch as these brothers like
Drake and Crispin overcome their odds and then
somehow through these actions of standing up
in the violence and whatever that they become
a family unit again or or some something like
that there's there's like that tale they could
have told but I really love the direction of
this because of that who'd done a kind of flare it
and then having this sort of action element to it
it provides something very unique and different
and very unexpected it's a nice flip on the
genre like the version I pitched you just now
is the very predictable version that it could
have gone down which could have been a great
character-driven Nuance piece sure maybe there's
a way that you could have done that as well then
it could have hit the right players still got
the cool violence but this version especially
with the Aaron character because like at the
very beginning of the film I don't remember the
specific lines but they're first seen together
Crispin and Aaron she knows it's a good uh uh
it's a good way of alluding to the fact that
she knows a little bit more about things than you
would expect when it comes to the background of
killers and stuff and survivalists so you're
you do slowly start to pick up and there are
these little clues that Kristen might be in on it
because like I thought that line of dialogue was
a little corny and it's like I've never seen you
behave like this when she's getting all assertive
after really getting lost in the blood and that
is the moment for her character a fight or flight
like what do I do and it's time to buckle down and
you get this sense that she had um an oppressive
childhood something that like I think the
performance is great and the writing is awesome
too because you get this sense that she had a a
real oppressive childhood and rather traumatic you
know being taken away at 15 and being brought up
to have these sort of sets of beliefs and that you
would the world is going to end and it's going to
be like an apocalyptic landscape you're gonna have
to learn to kill you're gonna have to learn to
survive in these really dark times and just having
the sort of beliefs and then you can imagine that
her character went down this path of having just
a completely different life and trying to get
away from all that and then bam and this incident
happens and all those things that were sort of
pushed away that you wouldn't even tell the the
man who she loves about her true past you wouldn't
even let him in on that piece of information
eventually you know some more I'm talking about
and I'm going back to the beginning of the moon
like man there were a lot of great Clues laid
throughout even with Crispin and the way how he
reacts to the family of when she's like a lot of
people would love to have parents like yours and
you could see how uh resistant he is towards
just receiving that and taking that anyway
um when it when it came to uh her character you're
watching as everything about her is just becoming
the full survivalist everything she was sort of
raised to be in her early ages of life that they
talk about you watch as she sort of morphs into
this by the very end you know it's step by step
being cautious being cautious and then eventually
just full on violence breaking through and I love
the trajectory of her character and I thought
the performance was awesome and the way the movie
starts to take some turns with you know slowly
showing The Killers having the reveals there and
then before he know it when they put their masks
on they're not even scary and you just get you get
to the point where you just want to watch her mess
all these guys up I thought was excellent and it
was fun it was pulpy it was inventive with some
of its kills it was disturbing but it never got
like too mean-spirited to the point where uh you
know like sometimes in certain movies I like I
like good campy violence and I like Pulp and all
that I I like Gore I I do enjoy it and there are
times though contextually where I go this is just
too mean for my spirit like in Halloween kills
there's this early on in the films if you haven't
seen a slight spoiler where Michael Myers kills
this old couple and then uh while the old woman's
dying she watches as Michael is like experimenting
with which knife to use by stabbing it into the
body of the Dead old guy and I'm like why'd she
have to be alive to witness this this is so mean
like I watched that film every time I see that
movie I'm like this is just mean that's mean I
don't like it like there's mean stuff here like
brothers killing brothers and stuff they're just
killing their family members it's mean but there's
a certain tone that the film strikes where it
doesn't cross into two mean-spirited there's
a there's a sense of fun even amongst the more
like disturbing family qualities to it there's
a there's a morbid Macabre type of sensibility
that I really enjoy and yeah I remember Christmas
I thought he I the crisp and twist because like
with the brother Felix and then the Z the woman I
it wasn't surprising I I had a thought going
off in the way they were Framing and I feel
like Adam Winger wanted to kind of clue you in
that he was part of it Crispin for some reason
I I just thought he might just show up at the
end uh part of me was worried that they were
gonna pull some [__] where he just walks
through the door and the ax hits him like I
was actually really concerned that might happen
but they didn't do that and they instead gave us
a Twist that lined up it made sense it makes
sense to everything else and while there's a
lot of like Exposition dumps I thought they used
it in the in the right right framing like it's
it's certain Exposition and be forgivable again
tone and and again you know like when Felix is
freaking out explaining all the things that are
giving all the information to to uh Aaron while
she's hiding behind the corners it works works
in the scene and even with um you know it's like
if Chrisman picks Chrisman calls Felix and she
picks up his phone and he just starts dumping
information like that's just a little silly but
when she when he is like revealing the whole plan
he's also pleading he knows that he could die
so he's also trying to bargain with her so that
way he can you know keep his life because he is
ultimately a coward and I I like the way they they
formed that relationship at the very beginning
because they they don't reveal like oh my God
is actually this ultimate Mastermind killer
guy he's not as cowardly as he as he puts up
you you get the sense of the with the history of
their relationship that oh he's the exact opposite
of the kind of of her dad essentially the way how
Aaron grew up and she talks about her father you
get the sense that you know as she wanted to have
a different roadmap for her life not the one she
grew up in that she was drawn to someone like
Chrisman who is the complete opposite of that
and they maintain that complete oppositeness while
those are giving us this villainous turn about
him and I think the way the a lot of the way the
family Dynamics I thought was fleshed out really
well like all that dinner table stuff seemed
part of it seemed improvised um it would have
just added the sense of realism like I like how
during the most violent hectic chaotic moments of
just pure intensity they would sometimes keep that
family bickering still alive it was great I had
so much fun with this the music choices were
great there's a lot of great framing devices
in here that do feel it feels like it's doing its
own thing kind of feels like the example when you
do the guest as well because um uh there are times
I was thinking of the guests did he do the guest
I'm looking it up he did do the guest okay yeah
that makes sense that makes a lot of sense that
way because there were definitely times I was
thinking about the guest and I really liked
that movie oh that would have been a good one to
react to on this channel why did I have to watch
it on my own time uh I really like the guest a
lot so yeah again that's another movie with a
revealing of the character throughout I don't
want to ruin that for anyone if you haven't
seen it watch the guest that's a great movie um
but yeah I think keeping it at Close Quarters a
contained film and the the way the reveals
went down I thought I had a lot of colorful
personalities to a lot of the characters
and it was just it was fun that was just a
really fun horror movie it was fun it was the time
suspenseless and had some really good jump scares
I'm trying to think of something I didn't like
and just because I feel like I gotta contribute
something to the like a criticism uh other than
some points of expositional dialogue that didn't
quite click with me but I was so invested in
the main character and I think the way how you
discover who she is through her actions is is
great and yeah no it was this is cool it's a
cool movie man it's cool I like how it took its
turn into sort of a b pulpy film from a from a
suspenseful home invasion movie to a like a pulpy
cathartic violent action film that was awesome
kind of like the cast and um guys what do you
think about this movie you're next I thought
this was awesome this was a really awesome film
and uh I'd like to watch it again and sort of
just study it because I thought there was some
wonderful composition to the shots because so
much of it is handheld yet it also to really
add up that intensity beef up that intensity
yet at the same time there were some just
really great composition with its shots and
a lot of messing with perspective I thought was
awesome that it constantly had this voyeuristic
touch especially in the first half um a lot and
watching how the table's turnover time is great
ah drake drake drake drake drake drake there's
some stupid character choices of course but you
know as again when you get into this like fearful
state I'm like I don't know what it'd be like to
be in a situation so would I be the idiot who runs
out the door sure why not I mean I'd like to think
I'd be logical and composed and be [__] Aaron in
this situation but I'm like maybe not I'd probably
freak out too at some point and make the wrong
call and split up or something like that when
I shouldn't be splitting up but for the most part
now this is good it was great it was a great time
I could see why people Rave about this movie
Ladies and Gentlemen leave your thoughts down
below leave a like subscribe click that Bell
and last but not least let's end this with a
kale Linden Mikhail if I was stuck in a home
invasion situation I feel like you'd be the
right guy to know because there's something about
you that just reads a pure intellect especially
with the kind of films you're really into I feel
like you'd really understand what kind of weapons
we need how to set up Contraptions all kinds of
gimmicks and gadgetry probably go on MacGyver
on everyone's asses and that's the kind of guy
you need in a home invasion situation some kale
I hope that the time I take a trip to Sweden that
eventually when I'm in your home chilling getting
to know the family that some people try to break
in and maybe annihilate us and then that's when I
get to see the true side of Mikhail come out the
monster within and he tries to resolve this guilt
by staying a loyal super sexy reject or patreon
page Thinking by giving that will absolve him of
the monster within him but it won't if anything
I'm just going to use all the earnings from
patreon to make sure to hire these burglars to
break in just so I can Unleash the Beast Within
you and force all that repressed trauma to come
out of you because that's the way I roll Mikhail
and I love my people at our patreon just that
much that I want to see their true colors go back